>>> NASA'S LONG AWAITED ARTEMIS
1 MISSION WAS POSTPONED AFTER AN
ENGINE COOLING ISSUE WAS
DISCOVERED.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
FIRST IN A SERIES OF MISSIONS
THAT WOULD RETURN HUMANS TO THE
MOON FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
1972.
THEY WILL TRY TO LAUNCH AGAIN AS
EARLY AS FRIDAY, BUT HERE'S WHAT
THE ARTEMIS 1 MANAGER THINKS
WENT WRONG.
>> THE COMBINATION OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET THE ENGINE 3 CHILLED
DOWN, AND THEN THE EVENT VALVE
ISSUE THAT THEY SAW AT THE INNER
TANK CAUSED US TO PAUSE TODAY,
AND WE FELT LIKE WE NEEDED A
LITTLE MORE TIME.
THERE WAS ALSO A SERIES OF
WEATHER ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE
WINDOW.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN NO GO FOR
WEATHER AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
WINDOW DUE TO PRECIPITATION, AND
LATER ON IN THE WINDOW, WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN NO GO FOR LIGHTNING
WITHIN THE LAUNCH PAD AREA.
>> LET'S BRING IN ASTRO
PHYSICIST NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON.
HE JOINS US LIVE, ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HADEN
PLANETARIUM.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.
I'M NO ROCKET SCIENTIST, JUST A
TV JOURNALIST, WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY MUCH HARDER, BUT AN
ENGINE BLEED SOUNDS BAD TO ME.
ARE YOU SURPRISED WHEN THESE
THINGS CROP UP AT LIKE THE 11th
HOUR RIGHT BEFORE TAKEOFF?
>> NO, I MEAN, IT IS ROCKET
SCIENCE, AND IT'S HARD AND IT
REQUIRES A LOT OF PEOPLE AND A
LOT OF THINGS TO HAPPEN
CORRECTLY.
ALL THINGS THAT HAVE TO WORK,
AND SO WE SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED.
ENGINEERING IS HARD.
SCIENCE IS HARD.
AND THESE ARE JUST REMINDERS OF
THAT.
BETTER THAT IT GETS SCRUBBED
THAN IT EXPLODES ON THE LAUNCH
PAD, SO TO CONSIDER THE
ALTERNATIVES.
>> CERTAINLY.
LISTEN, WE HAVE ASKED OUR
VIEWERS ON TWITTER AND INSTAGRAM
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PLATFORMS YOU HAVE.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SUBMIT
QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAD LIKE YOU
TO ANSWER.
I'M GOING TO START WITH ONE I
RECEIVED, BESIDES EXECUTING A
SAFE MISSION, OBVIOUSLY, WHAT'S
THE TOP PRIORITY SCIENTIFICALLY
OF THE MISSION.
WHAT TOOK SO LONG TO GO BACK TO
THE MOON.
ARE WE IN A MOON RACE.
I'LL LET YOU CHOOSE WHICH OF
THOSE QUESTIONS YOU WANT TO
ANSWER.
>> I THINK WE ARE IN A LITTLE
BIT OF A MOON RACE, EVEN IF NO
ONE ADMITS IT PUBLICLY.
CHINA HAS MET GOOD ON EVERY ONE
OF THEIR PROMISES, WHEN THEY
SAID WE'RE GOING TO PUT A
ASTRONAUT INTO ORBIT, THEY DID
THAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BUILD A SPACE
STATION.
THEY'RE DOING THAT.
AND SO THEY WANT TO SAY --
DECLARE THEY WANT TO GO TO THE
MOON, WE SHOULD REALLY TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY.
IF WE FEEL THREATENED BY THAT IN
ANY WAY, THIS IS THE KIND OF
RESPONSE THAT THAT TRIGGERS.
THAT'S WHY WE WENT TO THE MOON
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
YOU KNOW, OUR CLEANSED MEMORY OF
THAT PERIOD IS, OH, WE'RE
AMERICANS, AND WE'RE EXPLORERS.
WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A COLD
WAR, AND WE GOT SCARED WHEN
RUSSIA AND THE SOVIET UNION
LAUNCHED SPUTNIK AND WE HAD TO
RESPOND IN SOME WAY FOR OUR OWN
DIGNITY, OUR OWN PLACE IN THE
WORLD.
A LOT OF THINGS DRIVE SPACE
EXPLORATION BEYOND JUST
SCIENTIFIC MOTIVES.
>> THIS COMES FROM JOSEPH ON MY
INSTAGRAM WHO SAYS DOES NEIL
THINK WE'LL EVER COLONIZE THE
MOON?
>> YEAH, SO COLONIES IMPLY THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GO THERE AND
JUST HANG OUT AND NEVER COME
BACK.
BUT THERE'S THE LITTLE PROBLEM
OF, THERE'S LIKE THE NO AIR
PROBLEM.
OKAY.
I DON'T MIND GOING THERE FOR A
VISIT.
OKAY, AND THERE'S THIS OLD JOKE,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE RESTAURANTS
THERE, AND THEY MIGHT HAVE GOOD
FOOD BUT THERE WOULD BE NO
ATMOSPHERE IN THE RESTAURANT, SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE VISITING THE
MOON, BUT THE IDEA THAT WE'D
HAVE A PERMANENT COLONY, WHO
WOULD DO THAT?
I'D JUST STAY HERE IN ON EARTH,
PERSONALLY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO THIS NEXT QUESTION CAME IN
THROUGH TWITTER.
HOW LONG WILL THE MISSION TO THE
MOON TAKE AND WILL THE
ASTRONAUTS EVENTUALLY STAY,
RESIDE ON THE MOON FOR RESEARCH
PURPOSES.
I THINK YOU ANSWERED THE SECOND
HALF OF THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SO A STRAIGHT SHOT TO THE
MOON WHERE YOU SORT OF LAUNCH --
YOU SET OFF YOUR ENGINES TO EXIT
EARTH'S ORBIT AND COAST TO THE
MOON.
THAT TAKES THREE DAYS, AND IT'S
THREE DAYS BACK, AND YOU STAY ON
THE MOON HOWEVER LONG YOUR
MISSION REQUIRES OF YOU.
THIS ONE, ARTEMIS 1, AND I THINK
ALSO TWO, BUT CERTAINLY THIS
ONE, IT HAS NO PLANS ON LANDING.
IT WOULD JUST GO INTO AN ORBIT
AROUND THE MOON, AND TESTING THE
HARDWARE AND THE SOFTWARE, AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE WORK BEFORE YOU PUT
PEOPLE INSIDE THE ORION CAPSULE,
AND SO THIS IS A -- THESE ARE
IMPORTANT TESTS.
BY THE WAY, DURING APOLLO, WE
DID THE SAME THING, EXCEPT WE
HAD PEOPLE ON BOARD BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE ROBOTIC REMOTE
CONTROL ABILITIES THAT WE DO
TODAY.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SENDING AN
ENTIRE MISSION THAT IN THE
FUTURE WE'LL HAVE PEOPLE BUT
RIGHT NOW IT DOES NOT.
SO HOW LONG YOU SPEND THERE IS
UP TO WHATEVER ARE YOUR GOALS,
AND LIKE I SAID, GEOPOLITICS IS
SOME OF THE STRONGEST DRIVERS
WHILE NATIONS GO INTO SPACE, NOT
SCIENCE, UNFORTUNATELY.
>> NEIL, THIS COMES FROM MY ALEX
ON MY INSTAGRAM WHO SAYS WHAT
MEASURES ARE TAKEN TO STOP
ROCKETS FROM COLLIDING WITH
SPACE JUNK?
>> YEAH, SO SPACE IS GETTING
JUNKIER BY THE MOMENT, OKAY.
AND SO OFTEN THEY DON'T
TYPICALLY TELL YOU THIS, BUT
OFTEN A LAUNCH WINDOW IS SET FOR
MANY REASONS, BUT INCLUDING THE
RISK OF WHAT YOU WANT TO AVOID
SOME KNOWN SPACE JUNK THAT --
THROUGH WHICH IT COULD COLLIDE,
AND SO THE MILITARY AT NASA, AS
WELL AS THE MILITARY TRACKS
SPACE JUNK.
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO RUN INTO A
PIECE OF SPACE JUNK MOVING 5
MILES PER SECOND ON AN ORBITAL
INTERSECTION.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE BEFORE
IT GETS BETTER, AND I JOKE THAT
MAYBE ALIENS HAVE COME TO TRY TO
VISIT, AND THEY SEE ALL THE
SPACE JUNK IN OUR -- AROUND IN
OUR -- SURROUNDING THE EARTH,
AND THEY SAID FORGET IT, WE'RE
GOING BACK HOME.
WE DON'T WANT TO RISK LAND